I like what you said about how you when
you watch drifter you see that's we were
at that time and maybe whether it makes
you uncomfortable or not you you see who
you were and what you were going through
what you were trying to intend audience
to feel and you hear it with bands like
like let's say you two there are first
two albums very angry excellent albums
but different from newer ones where you
know life is maybe a little better money
is more plentiful so so I think people
are in a different state of mind yeah
but but I get it I was watching this
some talk show with Wes Craven and I
think was from like 1988 oh my god and
it had some of the commercials still
playing Oh from that time and this was
from like a talk show that I watched as
a little girl and it was like wow even
the tone of the commercials were more
upbeat the music everything was
different so the tonality of the world
was different then yeah so I think we we
reflect what you know and if you're
saying it 2015 people have come out of
the recession yeah it was a tough time
for everybody especially Millennials
because jobs were not what you know it
was a tough time for everybody I get
that you could have felt that it was it
was an angry time for a lot of people
yeah I mean I think I was just like
really attracted to you know exposing
just like ugliness of humanity and just
like the flip side of things you know
like serve Bret Easton Ellis kind of
like you know I mean how he would like
when he wrote like rules of attraction
American Psycho and all he's like he was
much more attracted to like the the the
flaws and people and I think um and I'm
oh you know I think the one thing that I
in very trying to do is very calm I a
common thing that no matter how
mainstream I would want to dabble in
like I am very interesting like very
flawed people and like very flawed
characters against even more flawed
characters and sort of like um kind of
like you know somewhat cynical outlook
on the world but like you know fun in a
fun exciting way like not like in a you
know you know kind of like a witty
entertaining kind of way and and but I
think I'm getting better about about
approaching it and doing the same kind
of intention but doing it a little bit
more
I mean lighter is not the best kind
we're just a little bit more like
audience friendly but still having that
same kind of outlook you know because I
don't want to I don't want to lose that
kind of outlooks I think that's what
what makes you know my stuff kind of
like
specific but but just doing it a little
bit more like you know a little more
something that like maybe my mom would
enjoy you know I mean sure if there's
not her kind of a just with drifter I'm
not sure if you're able to talk about
the budget and and some of that but I
was curious about how you do the
location scouting cuz you talked about
the desert yeah and how you were very
intrigued by the desert and I know the
deserts always intrigued me that there's
something frightening about it and then
there's a very mysterious and ethereal
about it because you could kind of get
lost in there and that there's all these
sort of interesting drifters and you
know there really are yeah and and you
kind of wonder what their their
background is well what is it about the
desert and how did you find that
location why just like the budget thing
well we shot the movie for like 40,000
he was like under for the grand so like
like but we shot a lot of I shot some I
tried a couple shorts like in Lancaster
area and Palmdale like so I kind of like
a little familiar with that area and
drifter was sorta like the first time to
really embrace my like fascination with
the desert because I've been really
fascinated by it for a couple years and
cuz I love stories about isolation and
and yeah I mean like it was just like
you know just getting old before your
time and just like burning so much gas
when he's just driving out to the
outskirts of because you know there was
no location manager or anything there
was like you know it's very skeleton
crew at like the bare-bones operation
with a nouvion like they just dry and
and and but the kicking off point was
like my cinematographer had known about
the town like that was in Bombay Beach
and you know we you know like the the
bad batch the the movie Keanu Reeves
shot there a couple years ago like they
had wrapped filming a few months before
we arrived so they had an eye but I
think mostly they do like photo shoots
and commercials there and they don't do
that many features and and maybe they're
starting to but but we you know like
that was like you know like we like that
was the kicking off point to write a
script around access to that town and
then um and then just driving around all
over the place trying to find it was
actually really since there was no
location measure and that movie was so
it was so much that movie is so much
driven by the set theses that like the
locations need me they were paramount in
that story and like if the locations
just didn't fit
and Emily was gonna get laughed off the
screen and like and I've seen a lot of
like really low budget post-punk Obagi
post-book post-apocalyptic stories and
like shooting in like Vasquez rocks and
like lenses you see like tourists in the
back you know it's like I want to shoot
up like no one shoots you know like dude
hit like forbidden places almost and
devils punchbowl yeah I love that stuff
I mean I want to go all the way to like
Death Valley it was way too far and but
I mean yeah me just like finding all
these like different places and yeah it
was like it was a I mean we were in
pre-production for a long time because I
just like there was like you know
they're very very small a you know crew
so it's like I could I needed I needed
time to get all that stuff you know and
and the locations were like the major
thing that was probably the most leg
because you know you don't want to break
the bank but you don't you want to make
sure the locations are as cinematic you
can get so it was like a lot of like you
know negotiating and shooting you know
and random spots all over the place and
and but yeah it was mainly yeah I was
like all around like Lancaster Joshua
Tree bomb abh Victorville like all those
and we shot a little in LA and like shy
like inside this like haunted house
which was a oddly enough like a right
around the corner where I lived it was
like I've been trying to find that
location for like forever and like I'd
go on all these houses that were like
there there were like just know what
they like you know they're just normal
houses you know and then they would not
was not at all like I was trying to look
for like like a haunted kind of manner
like like the tales in the Crypt kind of
house or something you know like and you
know and I was shocked that we were able
to get the house that we got because the
guy was just like a super nice guy and
just totally hooked us up with a great
deal on it and and and it was just like
when I saw the house I was like cuz I
just get so obsessive I loved locations
and I loved like the bigger the better
and like you know I just I like seeing
that house I was like and in fact it was
right around the corner like right under
my nose this entire took for like months
I was trying to find that place um I saw
this place I was like this is the this
is Peart has literally everything we
needed it all the rooms like they had
extra furniture I mean like literally
everything we need it was there it was
like it was almost like too
was very odd it was they just late it
was like destiny it was really really
great but yeah I mean the locations
that's like one of major like that's
like the one of the major things that
I'm very very like stubborn about in
pre-production because you know dictates
the quality of a movie and like and if
you I've seen films well I'd really like
crappy locations and they're just like
why would you ever use that and and so I
think um you know I mean you don't want
to be like you got to be you know
realistic at a certain point but but you
know you you don't there's difference
between being realistic and like
settling why you don't want to like say
I mean you you really want to make sure
that you can get like the the best
location can possibly yeah I mean like I
think a lot people just sort of like
that's fine let's just shoot there it's
jolly cool we'll just shoot around it
like you know I just its locations are
so so important so important I mean if
you're making a cinematic kind of story
it's like they're they're very very
important because they just like I mean
it just just dictates so many things you
know how did you deal with the wind and
the heat and also - I don't know how
close were any any types of stores or
whatever like so how are you dealing
with the remote location and some of the
elements I mean I will will be shun
before we shot like to filming blocks in
July and August of 2015 in July we were
shooting a lot of night stuff in
Lancaster and picture fill area and it
was like freezing yeah it was we have
this like one girl it was like she was
like covered in fake blood for like
hours that night and she was just like
shivering the inside like teeth were
chattering the entire time it was like
was rough but I like um but but yeah but
but that wasn't that was no nothing
compared to when we shot in the town
because the Film Commission I never
liked meeting with them they were like
laughing at us because we were shooting
in August like they were like even that
movie like even though I think I was
talking about like they they didn't they
something like April like and even then
it's hot out there and it doesn't start
to cool until October and we couldn't
push the October I just wasn't gonna be
one those guys like shoots you know on
the weekend and months later shoots
again I just too impatient for that and
and so
yeah I mean we shot like in the thick of
the August like literally the worst time
that you're supposed to be filming there
and I mare there was like we were so
caution if we could like afford a medic
to come out because we needed a matter
to come out but we were nervous that we
good for and then we finally did get one
to come out and and there were yeah
there are couple people that almost like
there couple moments of people almost
passed out and like there was just uh I
mean like it was it was a very it was
very intense it was like I'd never felt
heat like that before and Amer when we
first arrived everyone was like having a
great time I driving out there and like
the moment we first arrived people like
couldn't breathe when they stepped out a
car and because like the moment we
arrived we went right into filming and
and like people were just like already
and like feeling it and we had like four
more much more ambitious days after that
so it was like I think that hottest guy
was probably a 120 I think like and it
was like the biggest day - if it was
like the hottest day as well it was the
most ambitious than like but I think you
know looking back at it I think it
really dictated like people's
performances like I think it really the
freezing cold and the scorching heat I
think that really influences people
influenced people's performances because
they really like all that sweat salt
real I mean all that you know I mean
just all like the sunburn and all that
all that all that stuff's real and um so
I mean like that that that's you know
cuz that you know I I just love the
stories of like the original Texas
Chainsaw Massacre how it was like
scorching heat just like such a nasty
atmosphere and world they were filming
over locations they were filming in so
like kinda like you don't to touch
anything but it's just like you look at
the film and it's like and it lends
itself very well to it you know
you